interview a lot of people over the years
boys got the journalism the outlet to
tell these amazing stories and people
were doing and all these fighters format
your choice of witness is a perfect way
to do this
for those of you may not know is a
series as a series of oral history books
that collect a narrative generic merits
or people who have lived with
humanitarian right person to another
world they are postman series on soon
and Zimbabwe Burma I'm survivors Katrina
Katrina in prison Penn State's workers
the United States so ours is the ninth
of the series
we felt with Max that no series about
during crises complete it's the largest
humanitarian crisis to the Western
Hemisphere very but and through this
book he wanted to do is challenge a
little bit the ocean that Colombia's
nice crisis is over the past 10 years
that's been the overriding Arab states
that this conflict integration for about
50 years was winding down
and through the voices of these
witnesses that are in the book we sought
to challenge that notion man and giving
them voice and I just like to be a very
short part from the forward in the book
which is written by ingrid betancourt
she's loving politician heard her she
spent six years little over six years as
a hostage of the revolution to make
leftist guerrilla group of the country
and she was held with the other
politicians that people in jungle camps
for six and a half years yes or to write
the the forward because she very
eloquently wrote about
silence
and her aboard that she would process
one sense of shame
remembering is painful and telling your
story involves submerging yourself
deeply and intensely and aerostats
bringing forth a flood of uncontrolled
emotion you become conscious of your
most glaring vulnerabilities but sharing
is also your way out every time you tell
your story you can distance yourself go
ahead and take a step back you learn to
remember without reliving and begin to
recover you know we don't need to say
and you don't believe that everyone from
story has got through this process of
recovery there
different stages of their experiences
but it is which is be quick I wanted to
participate in in this process helping
people relive a retail without reliving
and comas conflict at history it's very
things it's messy a little bit about the
current state of the conflict plum is
often understood is just a truck war
where their sense of violence by drug
cartels the country bombings all are
complacent and that really is the source
files of every button but the human
rights problems in Colombia major
appliances
much more complex the country has been
experienced internal are accomplished
the past 50 years main actors in the
conflict are left-wing Gorillaz founded
in the 1960s founded marxist ideology
intended overthrow the state the two
main groups are the Revolutionary Armed
Forces Colombia FARC guerrillas and the
National Liberation Army of Colombia the
Yale Enderlin Gorillaz both of those
real roots exists today at bart has
about 8,000 10,000 members Yellen has
about 1,500 members their signature
crimes kidnapping and kidnapping
forcefully recruiting children laying
I personally and minds about 10,000
Colombians have been vacant land mines
more national those victims or civilians
they've also been killing smashers
that's one group those are best one side
of the conflict in 1980s right-wing
paramilitary groups cropped up rabid
country these groups large militias they
represented the confluence of interests
of landowners who become targeted a
gorilla extortion kidnapping as well as
drug traffickers wanted to defend their
power against guerrilla groups and also
want to avoid an extortion kidnapping as
well as the Colombian military which had
a counterinsurgency injected so there's
powerful makes of interest in gay prices
paramilitary groups which expanded
rapidly throughout the country and
accumulated incredible power allies in
Colombia Congress and even in the
national government those groups
officially participated immobilization
process between 2003 and 2006 which had
severe shortcomings and flaws and new
groups emerged after that process
paramilitary successor groups are
emerging from Montana government pulse
they also remove a certain ease and
civilians and then none funny military
is also is involved in the conflict they
were involved in extra visual executions
against civilians particular between
there's pee in crime in 2004 2008 where
the military would improve generally
poor young men execute them and dress
them up as rich presented this compact
is reported crimes of decline addressed
in the past few years with that those
effects beat the military has been
against millions all of these pieces to
cause force displacement or the
government numbers about ordinary club
kids have been driven from their own
since 1997 give me one of the highest
population internally displaced people
in the world which is what this was
about
so I'm going to read a passage from an
equal any when he was eighteen his
girlfriend became pregnant and he was
jobless at a time and he moved to party
southern Colombia receipt work at a at a
slaughterhouse and his job was making
any money and this is around 2000 for a
paramilitary group offered in work and
made mistake and he went with them and
they they took him to train came over
here his starboard we're name is being
driven to the training camp if Feldon
were driving for about an hour 45
minutes on a dirt road it was about
seven at night when the car stopped and
he took the blindfold off I didn't know
where we were all I knew was that it was
a jungle the pilots took me to a camp in
the middle of the jungle around 150 men
there and some women too they were in
uniform somewhere all agreeing others
who camouflage it were moves some had
tree has some handkerchiefs tied around
their necks there between 15 and 40
years old the older ones were the
commander's some of them were cooking in
a tent and smoke was pouring out of it I
was told to get a lot of food
wasn't hungry one of the paramilitary
said eat because you'll be hungry later
so I got in mine and I met a boy there
he was friendly and young even younger
than I was at the time I asked him I
asked if they were going to me he said
they wouldn't kill me but it's simply
been recruited that in there was
something that I'd be there for some
time they taught me things like how to
shoot another survival stuff the boys
will we hadn't seen his family since he
didn't grew did he said my family the
people here I can't call I can't
communicate with anyone else that made
me even more scared I was handed cut to
receive of food it was rice soup I hated
and then I was told to go to sleep early
because it would wake me up very early
the next day I wanted to sleep near the
boy who talked to me in line so I lay
down next to him on the ground I'm going
there plastic part the boy let me like
it I didn't think I would be able to go
to sleep and soon I started to cry the
boy told me not to cry I told him I
didn't want to be there and he said
there's nothing to be done now he told
me was the next day the commanders would
explain everything that once you're in
the only way she believes if you're dead
I cried even partying and the other men
were about this told us to shut up to
stop popping around but I was acting
like a little girl someone said we'll
teach you how to be a man here I quietly
says the boy please help me I don't want
to be here and he said I can't do
anything I'm just like you here I
explained them that came from a war club
or family
that comes to eastern plains to work for
my soon-to-be-born child he said that
even so he couldn't do anything somehow
I fell asleep I felt like I only slept
for about five minutes from the boy will
be I everything was silent dark he
whispered me to get up and not to make
any noise he told me I shouldn't put my
shoes on but scared in my hand that he
led me to a corner to hand it was
unguarded once we were outside again he
said you know my brother I'm helping me
because I understand that's how I wound
up here too then he said well let's walk
and we walked in silence for about 45
minutes over sharp rocks I didn't mind
the pain we reached the point and he
told me to run he said start running in
that direction until you find the road I
can't help you anymore because I have to
get back he told me that if I got caught
I couldn't save helping I thanked him to
put on my shoes and started running he
never told me his name I ran ran and ran
I was really scared the shadows of the
trees look like people as if they were
watching me the boy told me in a pine
road soon but I couldn't find it and I
said to myself I must be getting lost
but I didn't stop running I read and I
cried I slipped and I tripped and
sometimes I felt like couldn't keep
going I stood for a while to rest to
wipe away my tears and blow my nose on
my
t-shirt it was warm I can hear the sound
of the birds and the cicadas I tried not
to blame to close my eyes because I
thought I closed my eyes and may get
lost I was very anxious a lighter if
your car every once in a while so I knew
I was close to the road I kept running
until I found it I started walking
around along the road but I didn't know
which direction direction to go because
i was totally disoriented I started
walking to my right for about 15 minutes
then I job stop job stop it's scaring
the paramilitaries my past body under
pickups or motorcycles but not a single
part of the fun then I saw us coming I
waved it down and got in but the driver
didn't want to take me because I was
really dirty I was soaking with sweat my
shoes were money and my t-shirt was full
of snot and i only had something like a
dollar fifty all in points I said please
please take me but it's only one
kilometer the driver said get up I had
seen in the aisle the bus and asked the
driver in the passengers to help me
because I've been robbed I didn't say
anything about what it really happened
the passengers began to tell the driver
what's the matter take them don't be
selfish health most of onions are like
that so many is able to escape the camp
and make it to a nearby city of the
essentials money it's living he goes
there and try to get some ice cream so
he can leave the area and when he's
there paramilitary Sheldon's house and
threatened his mother and his younger
sister at that point telling a season
where he is we realize
siesta clean and he ends up going to
Ecuador where he he moves and eventually
his soon be where child is born and the
child or he s not a gay person to live
in the vernacular so right now man is
living in Ecuador's refugee and
struggling to provide for his family
sells handicrafts on buses zones that's
about as I've been inferred or there's a
movie called pursuit of happiness sorry
will spin after a solid but that's why I
have to be it's about a dad wouldn't get
ahead he has debts and so many problems
that his wife Lisa with their little fun
begins and he gets to walk with his
little boy he gets addicted he has no
job he has to go hungry in order to give
food was little one they have to sleep
in homeless shelters that movie really
got me I feel like it's mine with me at
the end of the film he becomes a
billionaire he employs many people who
try to like eat it that's something I
would like some day be well off so I can
give it hands many people in need my
children really love me they've
struggled with me we've been through the
good and bad when I a little bit of
money on a body massage if I meet them
sometime to say i want you to make the
burgers the way you make them so i went
out fast I've I found me I get spices i
make their burgers failing you a few
then you know what to ask God to help us
I always turns the baby Jesus on Sunday
I go to church and say baby Jesus I'm
here with my little ones every time I go
I leave something of mine they're so bad
remember me I used to leave little
photos I had
but then I ran out so once I let it
expire refugee claimant card sometimes I
feel better I met a girl here that I
like a lot just my landlord's daughter
the one who always helps out with my
kids I let me think this is the way she
acts with my kids but I haven't told her
anything because I feel that maybe she
doesn't have time for me because maybe I
don't have anything to offer I don't
have money and I don't have anywhere to
didn't bite your tears but the truth is
I had a heart and I fall in love and I
get excited I think that someday I'll
tell her that I like her so Dana
SiliconANGLE or struggling providers
families regular traumatic experiences
of sleeping a paramilitary can you know
some consequences if they were in
but I think something else is shines
through the narrative is
depart cesar gains resilience provide
for his family there's also acts of
kindness
colombian
on the bus who actually do their means
tri-gate with them make the bus driver
to to help me escape which could cost
you your life actually in Columbia with
their military or dependency so I think
that also comes through a lot of the
narratives all over in the face of
tremendous loss and violence a lot of
people are there were severely
situations
continue to finding love
about refugees
most of the right
but the vast majority don't actually
have refugee status Danny does
about fifteen fifty thousand
going to what max was saying about the
resilience we chose to talk to
displacement because this place is sort
of a secondary income is a shin people
leave their homes because they happen
but we in no way that is our purpose
liking these stories is to have people
feel sorry for they don't they are
incredibly strong and incredibly
resilient very very brave in no small
part
their stories to us sharing
this level of detail and many of the
marriages asked their own security
change their names to namsun
to protect them but others asked us to
to ask us to
specifically tell their story
let them close
she lives on the northern coast of
Colombia
the worst massacres
she and her husband were cooperative
and and so there are 27 family's
collection farming this land
military troops came and took over the
farm they existed and staying for a few
months and finally pledged with your by
City the barrel Tracy mobilizes Mac
subscribe they got back for their farm
and tried to recover what they didn't
lost in terms of the crops and cattle
and they were trying to find that our
method for clothes they collectively
bottoms
close and then we're about to lose a
part entirely and her husband propane
you started fighting against us in the
courts spoke out in the PM which sounds
really easy but nakid incredible bravery
because they're very powerful forces who
wanted to take this mark still go hijo
was received dozens of death threats
and announced every one of them
and he was killed may11
he was going down hard way back to a bar
from the village and
oh yeah
it's a little bit about what happens
after
I didn't leave the farm when they killed
her hitting the people from the
government's human rights office okay
should I don't think I'll ever leave
even though we don't know what his
killers have in mind for the rest of us
when rachel took the job as president of
the cooperative I didn't like the idea
because I knew that it carried risks but
today I'm the new questions since march
two thousand eleven I'm doing it out of
the love I had for behavior and the love
that he had for Nadia money I don't care
about the risk I'm doing it for him so
that his dreams is accomplished to see
madam I am free of debt and so that
people can say that a money is ours
that's what I think it would've what
does it works when we express the
opposing to these white horses that
would leave their homes again
and the power that that that all of
these narrators have to tell their
stories of bravery we're incredibly
grateful to everyone for sharing stories